i'm not even gonna lie man i left you
guys on one hell of a cliffhanger in the
last video
[Laughter]
i left you guys on such an insane
cliffhanger a part of me feels like it's
not fair and i should probably start
doing it but another part of me doesn't
want to stop so i don't
know i don't know i'm evil i am so evil
i'm a terrible person i'm like a
villager might okay so in the last video
we basically had this revelation from
alan the alien when he was talking to
omniman to nolan that they intended or
he intended to basically release the
scourge virus on earth and that the
scourge virus is known to kill
viltromics right it's a guaranteed way
to destroy what's left of the viltermite
race the problem with this is that human
dna is so close to vulture my dna that
it could very well wipe out humanity as
well and so that's why you have nolan
here who's like right off the bat no
right the people on earth are innocent
have you lost your mind and that's kind
of the crazy thing about this is that as
this fight breaks out between these two
this is a 100
philosophical argument right it's 100
philosophical we're not really debating
ways and means here right we're debating
whether or not it's morally ethical to
do this this is in effect the invincible
seemingly cosmic version of the trolley
card dilemma so for those of you guys
who aren't familiar with this uh the
trolley car dilemma is a utilitarian
dilemma basically by utilitarian being
the needs of the many outweigh the needs
of the few and so what you have in this
particular dilemma in this particular
scenario is that you're the conductor of
a trolley train and that the brakes on
the trolley train go out there's no way
for you to stop it the only thing you
can do is steer it one way or the other
and that at the end of each one of these
tracks is basically a deadhead right
that like the trolley car will hit it
and it'll stop and that'll basically be
it however on each one of these tracks
are people that on track a is one person
on track b is five people which one do
you kill one of those two groups is
going to die and so on the surface and
on the front face it's what you kill the
one person but then the situation
becomes more complex when you start
introducing variables but what if those
five people are criminals or what if you
can push someone in the way of the
trolley train and kill that one person
but save the people on both sets of
tracks right but leaving out all those
varying you know ideas and concepts this
is in effect a utilitarian argument
right that it's one of these things
where nolan takes the stance of no you
can't take the risk of killing what
could be an entire planet of people to
eradicate a small number of people and
so that in and of itself is a
utilitarian argument the risk is simply
just too high that yes the needs of the
many outweigh the needs of the few the
few here are the viltrumites who exist
on earth the many are the innocent
humans and that without any concrete
evidence to know for certain that the
scourge virus would not kill humanity
it's too big of a risk to take but the
funny thing about this is that no one is
looking at this in a microchasm no one's
looking at this from the perspective of
simply earth itself but one thing to
keep in mind is that alan the alien is
now in charge of the coalition of worlds
it's not just earth he's concerned about
anymore now it's the millions of systems
that are all part of the coalition of
worlds right all those planets that
exist out there the countless number of
individuals that would potentially die
at some future point in time if the
viltromites are allowed to repopulate
their race on earth which is the bargain
that was struck between omniman and the
viltrumites otherwise earth would have
been destroyed by the vulture mines that
if they're allowed to proliferate they
will go back out into the universe and
they will keep doing what they've always
done now there is a bit of a caveat to
this right but the thing to notice is
like this fight is knocked down drag out
right now one thing to remember here is
that we're alan the alien was previously
weaker than omniman that alan the alien
is one of these guys where he becomes
stronger as he recovers from various
conflicts that he's engaged in at this
point in time he's far stronger than
omniman is he's pretty far above him do
i think he's powerful enough to beat
freddie mercury no but he's still pretty
freaking powerful now the funny thing is
that in the middle of all this suddenly
oliver shows up here right now again
oliver as you guys know basically the
youngest son of uh of omni man and goes
to attack alan the alien and so when he
initially gets the upper hand it
basically kind of stops the fight by
just kind of like okay everybody chill
out what's going on here at the same
time of course you also have basically
the military forces of of allen alien
that show up and so ultimately you have
this scenario where it's explained by
alan the alien to oliver what's going on
right that there's this idea that the
vulture might exist on earth that a deal
was brokered between nolan and the and
and freddie mercury right the you know
thrag the leader of the of the
viltrumites that as long as the
viltrumites were allowed to stay on
earth they would interbreed with
humanity but they would also teach them
to basically become members of the
villager might race at least their
offspring anyway and that at some future
point in time presumably a thousand
years the villager might race would be
back up to their previous numbers and
they would leave earth and they would go
back out into the universe and basically
do their own thing and this was done
because had nolan and mark stood against
general thrag had they stood against
freddie mercury he would have killed him
he would he would have beat them to
death and then he would have killed
humanity and that basically would have
been it or he would have beat them to
death killed all the superheroes on
earth and then conquered the world and
turned it into a breeding ground and so
as a result of that the only way to
basically keep humanity safe and to keep
themselves alive was to broker that deal
but in the mind of alan the alien at the
end of the day the destruction of the
vulture might race has to be the number
one priority here and when all this is
explained to oliver that the scourge
virus could very well kill humanity but
the deaths of seven billion people on
some backwater world in order to prevent
the future deaths of countless people is
worth the risk right and so when this
explanation is given to oliver oliver
basically stands against omniman and
says he's right he's absolutely right
here yes it sucks at his humanity but at
the end of the day he's like we can warn
mark and adam eve mom's already here
there's no one else on that world that i
care about and the universe will
scarcely even know they existed in the
first place and so if the greater
universe is basically unaware of
humanity's existence outside of the fact
that the viltrumites are there which is
the only reason they even know earth
exists and that their deaths would
basically go unnoticed and unmissed by
anybody does it really matter that they
die and what this does is it brings in
this really really interesting argument
of a hierarchy of value we as people we
create a hierarchy of what matters most
we create a hierarchy of who matters
most in society here's a really good
example if your favorite celebrity in
the whole wide world came to you and
said hey my car ran out of gas down the
road i need five bucks can you give it
to me you'd probably give it to them but
if a homeless person came up to you and
said the same thing you would probably
turn them down the irony of this being
you don't know any more about that
celebrity than you do about that
homeless person you know who that
celebrity is in the public eye but who
people are behind closed doors is not
the same person they are when they're in
the public eye especially with a
celebrity where their career lives and
dies by how they're viewed by society
right they can't really be who they are
they for the most part have to be who
society wants them to be lest they see
the end of their career yet you would
give them the benefit of the doubt where
you wouldn't necessarily give it to a
homeless person and so given that kind
of nature it makes sense where oliver is
coming from here right he creates a
reasonable argument and saying like
there's no one that i care about now a
lot of that's also because of oliver's
detachment he was never really raised on
earth i mean he kind of was to a degree
but remember he ages faster than people
normally would and so where oliver looks
like he's about 14 15 years old in
reality he spent maybe a couple years on
earth and like that was basically it he
hasn't been there all that long it's one
of those things because following alan
making his case the response of nolan is
to make his case to oliver and what he
argues here is that he is not an anomaly
he's not something that just sort of
happened as a fluke it wasn't lightning
in a bottle nolan living on earth for
such a lengthy period of time changed
him because of what he saw about
humanity when he had a family when he
got married when he had mark it changed
his perception of the world and it
changed his mission in his life that he
was hell-bent on fulfilling his role as
a member of the vulture might race and
conquering the world making it ready for
the viltromites to do whatever it was
they needed to do to expand their own
empire and likely turn it into a
breeding planet but as he spent time on
earth and as he became more and more
attached to people on earth he
ultimately chose to defect from that but
here's the thing here's a big difference
and it's one of those big things that
nolan's basically skimming over here
nolan killed the guardians of the globe
nolan killed anybody who stood in his
way or who would have prevented the
vulture mites from being successful in
conquering the world it was not until
nolan had to fight his own son and his
son begged for his life that he
basically changed his tune that's what
did it that's what turned things around
for nolan anything else besides that
didn't have any major bearing here but
the argument he makes is they're going
to be on earth for a longer period of
time basically meaning they'll get to
where i was much much faster right
they're saying they need to be here for
like a thousand years a lot can happen
over the course of a thousand years but
the response of alan the alien is but
what if that doesn't happen you're
betting all this on yourself you're
saying because i could do it they can do
it as well and that would be a true
statement if we were talking about nolan
building a company or educating himself
growing wealth or something like that
right i mean if that's what we were
talking about improving his status in
life sure right because the ability to
generate wealth in america is not based
on a superpower right you can't see into
the future so you know what you should
invest in or anything like that it's
fortitude it's wherewithal it's drive
and ambition and the ability to make
sacrifices in the face of already having
made sacrifices because the sacrifice
you're making is in pursuit of your own
goal it's not a sacrifice you're making
out of the circumstance that you're in
and so because of this it's one of these
things where alan is right here when
he's like no like you're betting that
this race that has been around for
seemingly eons that that literally was
born and bred with the philosophy of
conquering worlds enslaving the universe
that you believe that they can somehow
change because you did that's not true
that's not how that works people don't
always change we're talking about a race
that wants to conquer and enslave the
universe this is not a risk that we can
take and so because of the fact that
nolan refuses to back down and because
he refuses to state like yes you know i
will i will stay out of your way you
know and i will let you do that that
he's ultimately taken by the by the
forces of alan the alien right and then
once he's able to break free oliver just
kind of gets the upper hand on him for a
moment starts to pummel him and then in
that momentary distraction when he goes
to fight his son he holds back and he
stops and alan the alien knocks him
unconscious and so when that happens
he's basically just sent drifting
through space and then oliver actually
accompanies alan the alien to earth to
help him fulfill this mission of
basically releasing the scourge virus on
the world in order to kill the viltor
might race knowing it may very well kill
humanity in the process and so following
that nolan basically crash lands back in
the apartment of himself and debbie on
telesco and debbie immediately freaks
out right she sees it like on the the
view screens and everything that he was
fighting the owl in the alien and her
initial thought is that he's looking to
conquer telesco right that he was faking
he was lying he was pretending to turn
over a new leaf all that kind of stuff
and that's when he says no like you
misunderstand alan's going to earth to
kill all the viltrumites there but he's
going to kill everyone on earth at the
same time we have to go to earth we have
to find a way to stop them and so with
that being said guys we're going to
bring this video to an end thank you
guys for watching
cliffhanger and i will catch you all
later peace